One of the first challenges that firefighters
face when they arrive at a fire is finding
a suitable water source that provides enough
water for the type of fire they are fighting.
Common sense tells us a car on fire will require
much less water than a burning apartment building.
There are formulas used by firefighters that
will tell them approximately how much water
is needed to fight a given fire (see bonus
facts below).
Fire hydrants are commonly color coded to
indicate how much water a particular hydrant
will provide.
This allows for quick decision making when
they are deciding which hydrant to access.
Water supply for firefighting is rated in
gallons per minute (GPM) available.
In most urban and suburban areas, water supply
is from a far away source such as a reservoir
or lake.
This water is pumped through a system of above
ground and underground pipes, then supplied
to all of the buildings and homes in a given
area.
Every water system is maintained by the water
district supplying the water.
Most is used for everyday purposes like drinking
water, bathing, doing your laundry, and watering
your lawn.
When there is a fire, water districts are
required to allow firefighters to access this
water for firefighting purposes.
They do this with the commonly known fire
hydrant.
Due to the numerous different supply systems
throughout the United States, there can be
a wide range of available supply, from 500
GPM or less to over 2500 GPM.
In an effort to make it easier for firefighters
to know what a specific hydrant will supply,
the National Fire Protection Agency (NFPA)
recommends that fire departments and water
districts follow a set standard of color-coding.
Known as NFPA 291, it says fire hydrants using
public water supply systems should be painted
chrome yellow, and their tops and caps should
indicate the available GPM.
Below 500GPM should be red, 500-999 GPM should
be orange, 1000-1499 GPM should be green,
and 1500 GPM or more should be blue.
If the hydrant is not hooked to a public water
system, but instead is accessing a private
system (as in the case of a shared well by
several houses in a specific neighborhood)
the hydrant should be painted a color distinguishing
it from a publicly supplied system.
NFPA recommends red.
OSHA (occupational safety and health administration)
further recommends that a hydrant be painted
violet for any source that is non-potable
(so what color should we paint a hydrant that
is non-potable and from a private source OSHA?….
sketchy!).
Furthermore, if a hydrant is inoperable, it’s
recommended that it be painted black.
If it’s only going to be inoperable for
a short time, it’s common to just place
a black bag over the hydrant.
GPM is only one of two factors of water supply.
The other is pressure, rated in PSI (pounds
per square inch).
All hydrants are assumed to provide at least
20 psi.
If it doesn’t, NFPA recommends that the
rated pressure be stenciled on the top of
the hydrant and on the caps.
They also recommend this for extremely high
pressured hydrants.
Too much pressure can cause damage to the
fire equipment if precautions aren’t taken.
The NFPA sets these standards and most fire
departments and water companies try to follow
them.
In the end however, these are just guidelines
and not necessarily requirements.
As such, not every area will follow these
recommendations.
In 2005, Firehouse.com conducted a poll of
firefighters and other fire service personnel
asking if their departments use this color-coding
system- 47% did and 44% did not.
8% of respondents did not have hydrants in
their areas.
In cases where there are no hydrants, water
supply trucks, known as tenders, will fill
up with water from near-by sources, such as
lakes and rivers, and bring it to the fire.
The NFPA recommendation is not the only color-coding
system used.
Many different municipalities create their
own, for their specific situation.
For instance, the Moraga-Orinda (CA) Fire
District has taken to color-coding the tops
of the hydrants following NFPA recommendations.
They then color code the caps for the specific
PSI provided.
They also mark for “dead end” hydrants,
hydrants only supplied from one direction.
They have their own hydrant body color system,
and an arrow system indicating higher pressure
hydrants.
They also provide Roman-numeral markings that
indicate where the shut off valves are for
that particular hydrant.
So when you are driving around your neighborhood
and see a hydrant painted a specific color,
be assured that color has a purpose.
If you are one that has a hydrant on your
property, it is not at all uncommon to try
and hide this “eye-sore” by decorating
it with flowers, butterfly’s, and all manner
of interesting artistry.
If you do, don’t be surprised if you get
a knock on your door from the local water
district or fire department telling you
your amateur art is not appreciated!